The general idea is that if we have observations
over time, we can facet by the primary unit, case,
or individual in the data set. For our yogurt data
it was the households we were faceting over. This faceted
time series plot is something we can't generate with
our pseudo Facebook data set. Since we don't have data
on our sample of users over time. Let's get back
to that plot to see that limitation. The Facebook data
isn't great for examining the process of friending over time.
The data set is just a cross section, it's just
one snapshot at a fixed point that tells us the
characteristics of individuals. Not the individuals over, say, a year.
But if we had a dataset like the yogurt one,
we would be able to track friendships initiated over time
and compare that with tenure. This would give us better
evidence to explain the difference or the drop in friendships
initiated over time as tenure increases.